tiempo para la información económica en
france 24 me acompaña en el estudio
nuestra compañera daniela blandón danny
estamos hablando mucho acerca del nuevo
gobierno que formen los talibanes pase
lo que pase tienen desafíos económicos
muy grandes por delante claro que siguan
pues este país de 38 millones de
habitantes de hoy es muy diferente al
que dejaron los talibanes hace 20 años
cuando era una nación agrícola pobre
ahora hay una sociedad más desarrollada
con una incipiente clase media aunque
arrastra serios problemas económicos
causados por la guerra la corrupción la
extrema sequía y ahora el kobe de 19 a
ahora demos un vistazo a las cifras
principales la tasa de desempleo en
afganistán es de alrededor del 30 por
ciento y se estima que más de la mitad
de la población vive en la pobreza
de hecho naciones unidas cree que
aproximadamente un tercio de los
habitantes no sabe si comer a todos los
días
danny que se espera de este país que
además está perdiendo apoyo
internacional pues afganistán tienen
gran cantidad de recursos naturales sin
explotar eso no es un secreto y también
es muy dependiente de la agricultura
pero también es una nación cuyo gasto
depende en un 80 por ciento de la
financiación de la comunidad
internacional desde hace dos décadas la
agencia bloomberg estima que los
talibanes pasarán de controlar ingresos
anuales de mil millones de dólares a un
producto interno bruto que es casi 20
veces esa cantidad consultamos con el
catedrático internacionalista mauricio
jaramillo que retos van a tener estos
aviones
los talibanes reciben básicamente un
estado órgano totalmente quebrado
después de 20 años de guerra con la
congelación de activos del estado ganó
en el escenario internacional fondo
monetario internacional eeuu anunciando
que no va a entregar dinero por la vida
de la cooperación y europa en el mismo
sentido entonces lo primero que tienen
que hacer los talibanes concretamente
recuperar las reservas internacionales
el dinero que deben llegar por la vía de
la cooperación internacional además de
eso deben demostrar suficientemente
suficiente control territorial para
recolectar impuestos para la recolección
de impuestos necesitan además relanzar
la economía y eso depende en buena
medida de que puedan controlar las
fronteras que puedan tener el control en
general del país en este momento de una
crisis económica porque hay una fuga
masiva de capitales
la decisión ha sido limitar a 200
dólares a la semana y esto sugiere que
la situación es tremendamente dramática
en el ahí cuál es el sentimiento en las
calles acerca de este futuro económico
que se muestra tan difícil
-juan pues bajo el escenario actual la
desesperación financiera se posa sobre
este pero hay sentimientos encontrados
también unos están felices de que se
haya ido eeuu y reclaman más
independencia pero otros más están
preocupados por si van a poder llenar
sus platos de comida
buscan dar nuestro negocio se ha visto
muy afectado la gente no viene a comprar
cosas puede que tengan miedo de salir o
que no tengan dinero pero nuestro
negocio ha sufrido mucho también hay
muchos problemas con los servicios
bancarios el banco central está abierto
pero el resto de los bancos todavía
están cerrados huawei estamos muy
contentos con el emirato islámico porque
con la ayuda de dios han brindado
seguridad hasta ahora pero el problema
es que el negocio ha bajado un poco
espero que este problema se resuelva
problema
-juan y es que como una manera de hacer
menos traumática su llegada en el ámbito
laboral los talibanes han dicho que
quieren conservar un sistema financiero
en pleno funcionamiento y que le da la
bienvenida a la inversión extranjera
para explotar todos esos recursos veamos
qué nos dijo también nuestro analista al
respecto estamos hablando de litio
estamos hablando de oro gas petróleo
incluso el opio el litio por ejemplo hoy
es muy importante para la producción de
baterías y celulares
no obstante digamos que eso eso depende
de cuánto puedan aprovechar la el
reconocimiento que le está otorgando a
países como china rusia irán y turquía
muy interesados en esas inversiones este
digamos estas posibilidades dependen de
que los talibanes en primer lugar
renuncien a promover el extremismo
islámico que preocupa enormemente y
sobre todo a rusia ya china y también
depende en buena medida de las
concesiones que hagan en materia de
derechos humanos respecto de las mujeres
los grupos chiítas las minorías tayika
sus becas etcétera
y en la medida en que hagan esas
concesiones es muy probable que empresas
de europa y eeuu lleguen y ayuden a la
explotación de estos minerales que para
los afganos sólo se es es muy difícil
porque no cuentan ni con los recursos ni
la ni la tecnología pues veremos cuál
entonces china y rúsia y estos países
que van a hacer entonces en afganistán
con tanto por descubrir también hablando
con información económica muchas gracias
y gracias también a ustedes por
acompañarnos en france 24 la información
continua no se despeguen de nuestra
pantalla
i